You are listening to radio lab radio, w.
N y. S. C. E. N. N. P. R.
All right. Let's start with an encounter. Yes.
Hello? Hello. Okay. Can, can you hear me okay? I can barely hear you.
Okay, so this is a well, our producer, Lulu Miller, uh,
with calling around trying to find some stories for this hour. Let's see.
She ended up on the phone with a woman named Barbara smarts. Is that any better?
Yeah, Barbara Smith's is now with University of Michigan,
but years ago she was a field researcher in Tanzania working with the Great Jane
Goodall, you know,
following chimps at a distance and writing down everything they do and that kind
of thing. Right. And when she was in Tanzania, she ran into,
in Gumby national park,
particularly young male chimp name Goblin is where you told me the story of
Goblin.
Oh, sure.
First of all, what does he look like?
Well, he's an adolescent male [inaudible].
He stood up to come up to quite a bit above my waist. Yeah.
And almost immediately he started picking on me in a sense that,
you know, he would walk past me and just kind of jab me casually as he went by.
And sometimes he would punch me with a fist.
Sometimes he would just kind of whack me with an open hand or just kind of use
his body to just kind of shove at me as he went past. You know,
he'd look at me as he approached and I'd be going, oh no.
And is that, that's something they would often do with humans or was this no,
right, no, he was in a phase of life when a male, as a male matures,
he rises in rank and before he challenges any other adult male,
he rises kind of step by step through the female hierarchy.
He basically intimidates female after female until they give in and acknowledge
that he's superior and then he'll pretty much leave them alone. So, um,
he was at the point where he dominated all but probably two of the adult females
and you and me. So that's part of it is where Goblin wasn't.
The other part of it is that I'm really small.
So as you're out there doing your research, what do you think is going on?
Did you think he,
I just felt like he was a bully and I was an easy target. Yeah.
And in the evening I would say that Jane Goodall, you know,
tell her what happened. Yeah. Ask her what to do. And she would say,
just ignore him, you know? Eventually he'll get bored and he'll stop doing it,
which was, you know, this is kind of standard advice,
this sort of myth of total scientific objectivity.
Just ignore it and it'll go away. But instead he escalated.
I remember one time I was sitting at the top of a hill and he came up behind me
and jumped on my back,
which forced me to roll down hill and he kind of rolled down with me, you know,
we were like the ball rolling down a hill again.
I would tell Jane ask her what to do and she would always say the same things to
ignore it. But one day during, during the race, it was the rainy season.
So we all carried raincoats with us,
and when it wasn't raining, we would
carry them on our backs so that it wasn't in the way.
And Goblin walked up to me one day and yanked on my raincoat and these
raincoats, they were like our most valuable possession, you know, the raincoat.
So he grabbed it and he was, you know, he was gonna run away with it. Um,
and so we had this tug of war and so the two of us were standing facing each
other, you know, tugging on this, um, raincoat.
And then I did something that was not premeditated at all.
Um,
[inaudible]
I just leaned forward and I punched him as hard as I could in the face.
Oh my God.
And
what did you think, like right after you'd done it,
were you shocked at yourself that you [inaudible]
yeah, I'd never punched anybody. It's, you know,
much less these chimp who I was posed to be, I think from a distance.
So I think I was shaking.
What did he do?
He just collapsed. He like turned into a little baby, you know,
he collapsed on the ground and started whimpering and then he looked to Sagan,
who was the Alpha male at the time who was sitting nearby. And he was like,
Figgins little sidekick always kind of hanging out with Fagan and playing up to
him.
He ran over to Sigrun screaming like this being just beat up on me.
Come on, let's get her. And fortunately,
and did not take it seriously. I remember he just reached over with this,
you know, great big hand. And without even looking at Goblin,
he patted him on the head,
went back to what ever who is doing,
cause it could've been really bad if he had taken it seriously.
I did not go back and tell Jane Goodall I had punched Goblin in the nose and I
just, I didn't tell the story for a long time.
Why not?
Well, um, I think I,
you know, I would've gotten a lot of disapproval. Yeah. Anyway,
Goblin never bothered me again.
So here's the reason we played that story because here you've got this moment
where you've got a scientist Barbara smarts, who's at, you know,
a trained scientists get scientific rules of objectivity and all that,
and he totally loses it and she slips
[inaudible].
And for just that moment, she's not really a human. He's not really a chimp.
The raincoat is still the important thing, the borders.
It was really what's happening
now. We're used to thinking of borders now between us and the animals as being
fixed. And most people would say, this is good. Keep them there.
Keep us here, keep a separate, but
not in this hour.
You're gonna meet people who decided to go the other way.
People who are trying to intimate and I mean really intimate,
really big wild animal. Something you could either call incredibly stupid
or our last great hope because there are so many of us on the planet.
So coming up, we've got two stories of radical experiments in
Sharon. Yeah, I'm Jan [inaudible]. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab.
Okay. Story one.
This whole shown way began with a conversation with this fellow, Charles. CBRE,
I am. I'm an author and a journalist. Um, Eh,
and he wrote a book called the West Shula Woods accord,
which is a great book in which he tells a story,
which he told us in studio as well, uh, about a chimpanzee named Lucy.
So let's just start at the beginning. Who, who is Lucy?
Lucy is, um, a chimpanzee that, uh, actually, well,
this was found out later born to a circus entertainer born in their camp.
What country are we in in the u s they traveled up and down the east coast.
The main old chimp arc shows something like that.
They were very popular in the forties and 50s.
They were wildly popular apparently. Oh.
So this was a mom and pop entertainment operation that would go from town to
town in the Middle Atlantic states.
And so Lucy was born to two of the chimps that performed in this thing. Yeah.
And they used to do things like the Houston stage wrestling matches with human
beings.
The he-man of the town would come in and challenged the chimp to a wrestling
match. What would happen, you know,
a chimpanzee and adult chimpanzees about five times the strength of a human.
And this guy would walk in thinking, you know,
I'm going to give this chimp or I have no money and like one swipe of this
chimps four-part that the guy would be on queer street. It'd be carried out.
It would end so quick then how spam go.
[inaudible]
okay. So getting back to our story about, uh, Lucy, this is a story that, uh,
begins in 1964 and it's one that Charles would have never heard about had he not
bumped into this obscure
old memoir long out of print. Yeah. What's the name of the book?
Do you actually have it with you? Yeah, hold there.
It's called Lucy growing up human,
a chimpanzee daughter in a psycho therapist family by
Maurice K Tamerlan Maurice k 10 Merlin. He is the psychotherapist.
He's a psycho therapist
and he's also the dad in this story in his wife Jane, who's a social worker.
She's the mom. Now the thing to know was it, especially for Maurice Timberland,
this was more than just a baby chimp. This was an experiment. Yeah.
He wanted to know, given the right upbringing,
how human could Lucy become what he says early on in this book.
Would she learn to love us and perhaps have other human emotions as well?
Would she be well, well behaved, rebellious, telogen or stupid? What about sex?
Maurice Timberland actually died in 1989 but these are his words.
Read by radio host David Garland. Would she mother her offspring?
But she learned to talk. How intelligent might she be?
And so how did they get her? He says that [inaudible],
um, he and his wife Jane made all the arrangement,
went and got the chimp from the day the infant was born.
The mother was anesthetized. In the early morning of her second day,
Jane Fed the mother a Coca Cola, which had been spiked with fen secluding,
a drug which puts chimpanzees into a deep, pleasant sleep.
Um,
and the baby was taken away.
Jane named her Lucy and brought her home on a commercial airline,
carried in a bassinet her face covered with a lacy blanket.
We were blissfully unaware of the complexities we were creating on the day.
Lucy came home, the baby,
they are too old. Just two days old. So it wasn't leaning. No.
And that was part of the experiment. They bottle feed her. Yep.
She quickly learned to hold her own bottle a two months.
Her eyes would focus at three months.
She was trying to climb out of her crib to go to people and it's six months.
She was pretty mobile on all four lamps.
My morning goes on the, by the time she was about, yeah,
a year old, she was eating at the table with us for expense knives.
You would see us using silverware and immediately do so herself.
She began to dress herself in skirts. She would often grab my hand,
pull me to my feet and begged me to chase it.
Always looking back to see that daddy was not too far by the
[inaudible].
You know, he really went at this with this sort of full bore earnestness,
you know when he calls her his darling daughter and I took great pride in my
daughter's achievement. He does feel like a real parent to Lucy.
She was so responsive to being looked at held and stroke.
But he's also to make no mistake treating this as a very intense cutting edge
experiment.
The next phase of the experiment, which occupies a good deal,
the book involves one of those, uh,
talents that we thought used to only be limited to us language.
Okay. Can you introduce yourself please? Okay. My name is Roger Fouts. I,
I'm a professor of psychology and I've worked with chimpanzees since 1967.
Roger Fouts was called in by Maurice Timberland to address one of the crucial
questions at the experiment, which you learn to talk. Right.
And at the time he was the guy,
he'd just been part of a team that had a proven for the first time that chimps
could use sign language to communicate. So his job with Lucy,
what's the teacher had assigned.
And I think I, uh, came into her life when she was, as I remember, it was 1970,
I think it was four or five. She was four or five years old.
Roger taught her signs for airplane, Baby Doll Ball,
banana barrette right, Barry? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I was sort of like blanket p p the tutor friend babysitter that would come
over for a few hours though, tie each day in and spent some time just, you know,
just playing with Lucy Candy. I would work on signs camped,
we'd read books together or we'd go for walks and I would chat with her basic
cry dirty and he sends the Lucy enough,
just sort of picked it up that all up. It was like, again,
she learned some 250 signs. And the big question is, okay,
so is it me or mimicry or are they able to spontaneously create words and put
them together in a new original way?
And there's been a lot of anecdotal evidence that in fact,
Lucy did, um,
spontaneously create words in a later session when shown a piece of watermelon,
Lucy tasted it and she called it
candy drink. Huh. And, uh, radish, uh,
had gotten quite old and one day, you know,
she was calling it food and food for I think several days of the study.
And then she's decided to eat this old radish and she took a bite and spit it
out. And I said, well, what is that? And she called it cry, hurt food. Wow.
She would also lie to me. Yes. Yeah. Yep.
And lying we should also say is another one of those things that people used to
think only we do.
During one of my sessions,
I came in and she had a potty accent that she had been potty trained,
but sometimes she didn't always make it to.
And I was upset because I was now faced with having to clean it up.
And so I said, whose is that? And she said, sue, who sue sue was one of, uh,
one of my students that would come in and spend time with Lucy too. And I said,
no, Sue's not here.
And finally she blamed fessed up and said to Lucy and sorry. And so
sue, yes. This is sue Sue's heavy drum bar.
The Grad student of yours who says she didn't actually see that lie and take
place. Yes. Well, I wasn't there, but she told us that when she met Lucy,
she was blown away by, well, the incongruity of it all. Like for instance,
every time she'd walk in the House,
Lucy would just walk casually into the kitchen and search through the cupboard
for the kind of tea she wanted that day and put some water in a kettle and put
it on the stove and make us tea. Yep.
Became a routine. I'd come in and she would start the tea,
the casualness with which she did it. The kind of air about it that yes,
I'm making tea and I would like you to have some too,
because tea is what we did.
And so the thing to do is to sit down and to casually sip the tea with Lucy and
casually look through the magazines, listen to the radio,
and what magazines would she look at? Well, she,
she looked at I think house and Garden and um,
some magazines that had pictures of women and children in them,
whatever the timberlands had out. Wow.
Lucy had developed an awareness of our emotions.
If Jane is distressed Timberland's wife,
Lucy notices that immediately and attempts to comfort her by putting her arm
about or grooming her, kissing her. If Jane is sick,
Lucy would exhibit tender protectiveness toward her bringing her food,
sharing her own food. And as we get to this next part,
this is sort of the mid point of the memoir.
It's useful to sort of remember a basic fact of biology.
Speciation happens when you've got one group of creatures that gets divided into
two,
and then these two groups evolve away from one another and eventually they get
so far away from each other that they can't have babies in nature.
Make sure that they can have babies by making one species basically undesirable
to the other. You look across your baboons, you'll look across at a champion,
you go, Eh, yeah, you're only sexually attracted to your own kind.
That is essentially what a species is. Now,
this isn't something you're supposed to be able to learn or unlearn.
This is just the way it is. Yeah.
Which brings us to some troubling passages in the book. Um,
beginning really on page one oh five, can you read it yet?
And we should warn that, uh,
this next minute and a half contains a sexual reference.
One afternoon around five o'clock,
Jane and I were sitting in the living room when we observe this sequence of
behavior, Lucy for that and we're living, went to the kitchen,
opened the cabinet and took from it a glass over the different cabinet and
brought out a bottle of gin. Jen. Yeah, she loved Gin and tonics.
That's actually not the important part. It's what happens next. She takes her,
Jen goes back to the living room, sits on the couch and from a coffee table,
there's really no other way to say this. She starts to masturbate.
But even that's not the important part. It's actually in the very next moment.
Did a boundary that took proximately 6 million years to establish
dissolves. Nah, Nah,
Nah, Nah.
Mr Timberland sees Lucy doing this. Any things?
No, no, no, no.
This is a perfect experimental moment. So he runs off to the mall,
well buys a copy of playgirl magazine and brings it back to her just full of
naked guy. Yeah. And Lucy would, uh,
masturbate to these centerfold.
I was not a part of that. I was never there.
When Lucy looked at the Borno with sue says that she was there for what happened
next. Yes, yes.
I was there when she was introduced to her first a adult male chimpanzee.
Had Lucy ever seen another chimpanzee before,
ever seen another chimpanzee from the moment of birth. Wow.
She says they brought this male chimp and see if Lucy was attracted to
chimpanzee males and was she aye. Well,
the male chimpanzee would sit there with his hand held out toward her and she
was very frightened and she tried to move away.
It was then says sue, that she realized that in every way that mattered.
Lucy was no longer at chimp.
She was stranded right in between this great divide that I knew was there
between humans and non-humans and not, I did not know how to negotiate this.
There is no category in our language except a mythical one for something that's
not human and not animal.